as humans have gotten more energy
efficient and more industrious over time
we started eliminating certain types of
money as being useful because they just
didn't have a big energy component uh
you know maybe in a hunter gather
setting you know their energy component
was significant but when we enter like
the Industrial Age that it becomes a
small amount of energy relative to what
we're capable of of harnessing whereas
only things like silver gold and Bitcoin
can with withstand the ability to just
bring a tremendous amount of new energy
to something uh and it's something that
no single entity has to control uh and
it's just it's proof of energy
itself all right guys bang bang I've got
Lynn here with me Lynn I thought a great
place to start you wrote a book it's
called broken money what exactly is
broken about the money right if you're
going to title the book that how do you
describe why the money is broken so I
think why and how are two different
parts of the question I think why is
because basically of the 150 year plus
uh Gap like we've had between like that
we've had this period where transaction
speeds and settlement speeds are so
different that's a big part of what I
focused on in the book is that ever
since the invention and specifically the
deployment widespread deployment of the
Telegraph and kind of ushered in the
Telecommunications era um there's no
fast way to send longdistance value
without credit uh and so we we just
basically had more and more credit more
and more abstraction until we just kind
of like lifted off from gold and kind of
left it behind um but the the downside
of that gets to the the the how like
what's actually broken is that when you
look around there's 160 plus different
currencies each one's like a little
currency bubble and they're all
devaluing at different speeds so some of
the the most robust ones grow at you
know six to seven or eight% money supply
growth a year uh many of the developing
country currencies grow at 15 20% uh 25%
in some cases more per year and people
are just kind of constantly getting
diluted and so they're constantly on a
treadmill where you have to constantly
try to earn higher wages you have to
constantly figure out what you're going
to do with your savings you can't just
save it you have to invest it and so
that's like a treadmill that everyone's
on at different speeds um crossb
payments uh despite the fact that we
live in the telecommunication age are
not as effici as we probably expect them
to be you know if people 50 years ago
saw that the money system still in many
cases works the same way it used to
which just a little bit more um fintech
overlay uh I think they'd be surprised
at how kind of little we've developed
here uh and but the main issue is just
the fact that the way it works is that
it's become so centralized and people
are stuck in these 160 different
currency bubbles so what's interesting
is you're talking about kind of being on
these different speeds of treadmill and
really what's happening is uh the
measuring stick is changing at one point
in the book you say that sound money is
a measuring stick that never changes and
when we think about that uh let's say
fast forward we get back to a sound
money uh kind of foundation and everyone
is able to use that as a measuring stick
that we all agree on and it doesn't
change what will be the implications in
society for the average individual do
they start to change their consumption
behaviors do they actually start to just
become Savers and not investors how do
you see that playing out so I think I
mean the world will look different it's
always hard to predict the future but in
general uh investing would be more
optional so right now it's like a
necessity like for example no matter
where you are like I know people in
Egypt and what but as soon as they get
money you plow it into like real estate
or something you you don't just hold the
money uh because you'll it's like
holding melting ice cubes um and of
course in the United States we plow it
into the S&P 500 and other other similar
things um and so in that world saving
becomes more of a just a normal thing
and investing is more of a niche thing
an optional thing something you can do
and this particularly impacts uh uh
people in the working class or the
middle class uh in in you know in many
countries for example people really just
saving cash they're not even getting the
interest because you know bank accounts
have overhead costs and so if you have a
net worth of like $500 they often just
don't even try to go for that market uh
it's it's not a not something they they
care about the costs start to overweigh
any sort of like usefulness they get
from that uh and so many countries still
have underbanked people but in that
World um saving just makes more sense
saving just works um better uh and also
the the contracts that people do in
society shift a little bit more to
favoring the status quo so in the you
know whatever you have a contract
negotiation what ever the current
contract is is kind of like the default
starting point and the entity that wants
to change it the onus is on them and so
in a world where there's inflation every
year anyone who's trying to get higher
wages or raise their rent for their
tenants or um raise their prices as a
small business or something it's always
on you trying to make that action and
that's particularly hard for for wage
earners because there's an anchoring
bias because of that status quo so
someone comes to you and says I want a
five six you know 7% raise
uh you think why are you five six 7%
better than last year um but really
they're not it's just the money supply
was so diluted um but realistically
they're going to get you know 3% 4%
increases and so they're going to slowly
kind of get eroded compared to the rate
that money supply is Growing Up house
prices are going up with things like
that a lot of people change jobs uh
unnecessarily just because that's
actually a way to kind of restart the
anchoring bias and get the wage that
they can't get at their uh initial
employer which is inefficient um but in
that world of sound money uh the
existing status quo have a stronger
negotiating position even if your salary
is not changing if your money is hard uh
and and productivity is increasing
you're getting a small real wage uh
increase every year uh if you're getting
one or two% increases on a sound money
uh you're doing well um and if there's
so much deflation the employer wants to
reduce your wages well that's going to
be tricky for them to do they could try
maybe maybe if it's you know it could
happen but it's unlikely basically it
just starts favoring the productive
class rather than the Arbitrage class
and I think that's that's good for
society I think a a sign of an unhealthy
system is when
Engineers uh go work in Wall Street
instead of and can make more money there
rather than go work building products
and yet that's what we see a lot is that
the best place to make money relative to
your training really is Wall Street like
people with a bachelor's degree can just
make an enormous amount of money because
that's that's the source of Arbitrage
and I think that that that that gets
greatly minimized in that other world so
one of the areas of diversification that
I think about is really there's almost
like two different uh levels to this the
first is uh there's a very large portion
of uh our population who they have no
diversification because they just save
in dollars that as you called you know
melting ice cubes they just kind of Melt
Away uh the other side of that economic
ladder if you will these people are very
Diversified they have multiple
Investments they're getting out of cash
and whether it's in Egypt and kind of
buying real estate or it's here in the
United States and they're just simply
putting into the stock market they're
trying to get out of the melting Ice
Cube once you get into the investment
class then what you start to see is some
people are heavily concentrated uh they
may have one or two Investments and then
there's other people who are trying to
protect their uh kind of Investment
Portfolio and they'll become very very
Diversified if we get back to this sound
money uh kind of driven world how do you
look at diversification does everyone
for the most part it it's kind of flips
and we become a majority saving uh
economy and those who choose to invest
may only invest in one or two assets or
is it more so there's just additional
optionality and so people have more
choice and the people who are the least
educated the people today who are just
saving they're the ones who really get
uh kind of the benefit and the people
who are investing they're still going to
have the same complexities and
challenges of trying to allocate Capital
to outperform uh whatever the money uh
and kind of the value of that money is
yeah I think the high conviction view is
that overall saving just becomes more
important and investing becomes that
more Niche optional thing you can do
less necessity
um at but the lower conviction thing is
what would that what would those
Investments look like like what would
people be more Diversified or less
Diversified in that world I don't really
know uh certainly people that are trying
to build real wealth quickly would want
to probably be more concentrated that's
you're trying to outperform um overall
investment selection would still be
similar there's and but it's just like
that's something that professionals do
it's something that if you spare Capital
it's something you can go into um but
it's just not this necessity so the the
overall importance to that in society
it's gets just downgraded it becomes
more kind of utilitarian um and another
key factor is that right now if you have
a lot of assets you can get access to
cheap credit because you can use those
assets as collateral you know obviously
credit's a little more expensive today
than it was a couple years ago but on
average in society you can get a much
cheaper credit than someone who has no
assets um which of course is going to be
true in any system uh no matter if it's
hard money or soft money but when you
have soft money uh when the unit of
account itself is always shrinking it
boost the um importance of having that
cheaper credit because you're you know
all all the wealthy people that have
assets and that have purpos some degree
of liability attached to it could be
mortgages could be other things you're
basically shorting it's like an extra
source of wealth creation you're
shorting society's devaluing unit of
account and that's like one of your
long-term kind of uh sources of wealth
creation that the kind of working class
and blow is kind of locked out of um but
in a world of sound money uh debts are
more strategic with their purpose uh
there's there's no reason to have like a
just like a long-term short on the
currency because the currency is going
to outperform most things even things
like um homes which are really
consumable durable so not fre
Investments for the most part but we
treat them like that because in this
world where you can attach a a low
mortgage to it and you're shorting the
unit we turn them into Investments so in
that in that other world you you kind of
return more towards them being like a
baseline consumer uh durable and
Investments become more um
strategic one of the biggest questions
that I get whenever I start talking
about Bitcoin reaching any degree of
mass adoption and really becoming the
center of uh the financial world is okay
well everything that I've been told in
this kenian view is that we need
inflation to Spur uh consumption we need
inflation to Spur investment uh if we
move to a deflationary type asset or a
sound money type asset no one's going to
buy anything and no one's going to
invest anywhere how do you think through
what actually is true and and whether
the critics have a point in uh lack of
inflation driving a behavior change that
could be negative for society in the
economy versus no actually it's a
positive so I think we have we have two
um specific examples that help counter
that one is if you look back at the
1800s um that was an era of mostly gold
and silver is money uh there's there's
you know virtually no inflation United
States outside of kind of temporary Wars
uh basically you a benchmark of you know
almost no inflation from the founding of
the country up until you know kind of
the creation of the Federal Reserve um
no structural inflation and yet that was
the period of like rapid Innovation uh
basically railroads automobiles
electrification uh different types of
engines were being built new types of
energies were being extracted and used
in various ways um just a a huge era of
productivity uh across kind of the world
uh but especially in these these sound
money environments and it was clearly no
hindrance to them so I think that's the
first example the second example is that
in Tech today um you know a lot of
basically the cost C of a gigabyte of
you know storage you know goes down a
thousandfold and instead of just
deflating that away we we use a thousand
times more gigabytes than we used to uh
and so basically with uh cheapness comes
abundance you you can use more of things
that are valuable um and you know there
there's kind of like a um when people
make the argument that you need to
invest if you're because or that a
strongly apprecia unit account would
hinder investment they're kind of double
counting it because you only get that
account that unit of accounts only
appreciating if technology is getting
better over time you know if society's
not advancing your unit of account is
actually not buying you more right if if
just we just kind of get stuck into a
status quo and all we're doing is kind
of maintaining our existing uh uh world
uh then say a Bitcoin is just still
going to be buy the same amount year
after year after year um so you're not
really getting inflated away but you're
not strengthening either only if Society
is if Investments are happening if
productivity is happening uh will that
Bitcoin be able to buy you more in the
future than it can today um and so you
it's like people say well no Investments
going to happen because your your
bitcoin's always uh going up uh but it's
like well it's only going up because
investment's happening um and and so
basically if if anytime you have a skill
or a niche uh you can likely find a way
to have a decent chance of of say
outperforming Bitcoin you're you're
you're going out and using your time and
energy and and expertise and knowledge
to go do something that's more useful
than just holding it uh and if you're
deploying Investments you know you might
be more selective which which might slow
down certain ideas but you're also
reducing
malinvestment uh and so th those kind of
balance each other out and that's what
we see again it's not just Theory that's
what we see in in history is you know
the Renaissance happened also on a sound
money standard uh like I said the the
the whole kind of the golden age of
innovation in the 1800s happened on a on
a money standard um and so that I think
that there's no reason to expect it
would be different under a Bitcoin
standard uh and you know like I to use
Egypt as an example you know there's
literally like a bunch of empty homes
there that people just they have a
second home and just leave it empty
because it's like well you know maybe I
can rent out later or like I have just
want to have something tangible rather
than hold the currency and and the local
stock market's not great uh in dollar
you know in kind of compared to other
assets so there's this malinvestment
that that gets redirected purely because
money's bad and if that money was
Stronger sure people might be more
selective on investments but they also
would make a lot less bad Investments
and so I think the overall percentage of
Investments that are there would be on
average more efficient more focused uh
and less malinvestment
oriented so there's four ideas that I
pulled out of the book uh that I think
are worth talking about and would love
to hear you expand on more so the first
is energy as the Arbiter of truth I
think this is a concept that when you go
when you actually study the energy
markets when you study how energy has
been kind of harnessed throughout the
years and specifically in in the
technology sector uh it becomes a little
bit more obvious but how do you think
about energy as the Arbiter of truth
especially when it relates to money
today's episode is brought to you by
trust and will I've gone through a
number of different changes in my life
over the last few years I got married I
had a kid and I had to start thinking
about how could I ensure that my wife
and my child would be okay if anything
ever happened to me that's where trust
wills and estate planning come into play
now most people what they do is they get
introduced to a friend an uncle or
someone in their local community it
tends to be someone who's really
expensive a lawyer an accountant or
somebody who does Estate Planning and
they just simply are using a one-size
fits-all template and just telling you
pay me thousands of dollars and I'll use
the same thing for you as the guy down
the street but that's not what trust and
will does they have a trusted online
estate planning product that starts as
low as
$159 which allows you to now protect
your legacy from the comfort of your own
home leverage their excellent customer
support available via phone email or
chat they have thousands of five star
reviews and a rating of excellent on
trust pilot it takes most people 20 to
30 minutes to complete their estate plan
with trust and will and not only that
but if you go to trust and will.com pomp
you'll get 10% off plus you'll get free
shipping of all your estate planning
documents so go to trust and will.com
Pomp and make sure you get an estate
plan in place whether it's for you or
one of your loved ones having a trust
Andor a will can literally be the
difference between someone being taken
care of and someone not go check them
out today at trustand will.com pomp so
um basically everything we do in the
economy is kind of one or two things
either we're getting more energy per
capita or we're using that energy more
efficiently uh you know for example
energy in a processor the both the
construction of the processor and then
putting energy into the processor to
actually make it work that's a very high
efficient use of energy compared to
other things we can be doing uh and so
that's that's really what our economy
and our interactions are is basically
just harnessing different types of
energy using them uh and in the book
specifically um the reason I use energy
is the Arbiter of Truth is that's in the
chapter that kind of goes over the
different consensus models like proof of
work versus proof of stake and the
importance of energy is that it can't
really be gamed uh you know there
there's no kind of cheat code for like
just um getting energy without cost for
example uh and so part of the reason why
a gold coin has so much value is because
there's so much energy density in it in
the sense that in order to get a gold
coin one ounce gold coin you have to
move like a ton like tons of rock uh you
you have to go out spend like first it's
the efficient part first you have to
kind of use technology or other
techniques to find the the deposits
where it's it's more dense in the crust
than elsewhere uh then you have to
basically
build roads build infrastructure to get
to that mine then you have to actually
have all these like excavation equipment
and dump trucks and all that you're just
you're you're spending a tremendous
amount of like diesel fuel literally
plus labor plus everything else
materials uh which are energy intensive
to extract the the tons of rock get the
you know sift through get the gold uh
then refine it into a single you know
ounce of of of gold or you know bigger
bar things like that and basically that
is like that's proof of energy when you
give someone a gold coin you're you're
saying this is proof of a tremendous
amount of work was done uh you can't
just print this um and even ma major new
deposits they can be found it's still
very hard to dilute this quickly because
a tremendous amount of energy has to go
in to actually extract those new
deposits and so whether it's Bitcoin
whether it's gold um whether it's silver
even to a lesser degree it's basically
proof of energy and that's one of the
hardest proofs to ever kind of Forge um
as long as the the substance itself has
some sort of verification method like a
Bitcoin you have a full node gold you
have various techniques especially the
smaller and more intricate like the gold
is the easier it is to confirm that it's
you know not just tungsten wrapped in
gold um and that's it's proof of energy
and so as humans have gotten more energy
efficient and more industrious over time
we started eliminating certain types of
money as being useful because they just
didn't have a big energy component uh
you know maybe in a hunter gather
setting you know their energy component
was significant but when we enter like
the Industrial Age that it becomes a
small amount of energy relative to what
we're capable of of harnessing whereas
only things like silver gold and Bitcoin
can with withstand the ability to just
bring a tremendous amount of new energy
to something uh and it's something that
no single entity has to control uh and
it's just it's proof of energy
itself later in the book you write in
the modern era energy abundance and
technological enhancements have broadly
improved human well-being but the global
monetary system has been slow to keep up
when you think about uh the advancements
of energy and all of the benefits and
and kind of that arbiture of Truth okay
got it why is the global monetary system
so slow to to uh kind of uh run
alongside it and obviously in the book
you dive into a number of different
solutions that you think are possible
but but what is really the the greatest
barrier right now between where we are
and where we need to get so I think it's
a great question I think um one of the
key things that people assume about
technology is that it's it's kind of
linear and smooth and exponential like
that every year technology gets a little
better than the prior year um which is
kind of true on net if you look at all
Technologies but in any one field
usually you get like a some sort of
pieces come together and you get like a
boom of technology and then you kind of
eventually stagnate for a period of time
because there's just not another
breakthrough so anything becomes very
incremental a really good example of
this is Aviation and Michael Sailors
uses this example because he you know
he's literally an aerospace engineer by
training uh which is basic basically you
know for thousands of years we make
almost no progress on flight um you know
closest you get is like Da Vinci drawing
about it uh but no no progress then they
get a little progress with like hot air
balloons and airships that's kind of the
first like step change um but even that
just kind of stagnates not not super
impressive but when you specifically
find hydrocarbons and aluminum and put
them together then you just dramatically
just you know when you have the when you
have an internal combustion engine when
you have Machining when you have
aluminum when you have hydrocarbons we
just have this like golden age of flight
for like 60 years you go from right
Brothers to the Moon in like a one human
lifetime it's like remarkable um but
then we actually kind of stagnated again
I mean the fastest um uh uh you know
kind of military Mann jet uh was like
the Blackbird like in the it was I think
the 60s 70s I forget when it was built
but it's like they it hasn't really
changed since the 70s um our ability to
send humans into space you know not
really G we not gone back to the Moon uh
after the initial several uh rounds um
basically we we in some ways we've taken
steps back uh the most Innovative thing
we've done on commercial airlines is put
wing tips on them to make them a little
bit more energy efficient and improve
their avionics their in interior stuff
um and so their their field of Aviation
has been an example of stagnation um for
a long time and it just shows that you
know you have these kind of Step changes
and that's normally how things go in any
in any one given Technology field and
with money I think that's basically what
we've been stuck in is that the you know
the telegraph was a kind of a boom for
ways to transmit money basically there
there are a couple step changes in
history one was like you know the
inventing of of clay and Papyrus for
example writing that was a literally a
technology that empowered money then
things like um Papyrus then like things
like paper specifically so paper and
even things like book binding on top of
paper so there's like things we don't
even think about today that were
actually Technologies of their era then
there was like the printing press that
actually was another huge piece of
technology for money um and then there
was a telegraph uh and really since then
we you know things kind of look similar
now than they looked 50 years ago in
large part because we still have that
existing technology set um and then
there's also Network effects I mean
money is now closely associated with the
government itself uh and it's a network
effect type of good and so it tends to
be you know kind of a long lasting thing
that's very challenging to disrup
and really Bitcoin and and things like
stable coins and things like that that's
kind of the the latest boom we have uh
that can Usher in like a whole another
period of of growth that we've not
really seen in a while so I think it's
it's mostly a technology reason why
money is just not really been growing in
in our lifetimes as fast as other things
uh and the other part would just be
basically trench Network effects so you
have this quote um from Nobel laurate
Economist Frederick hyek uh where you
say quote I don't believe that we shall
ever have a good money again before we
take the thing out of the hands of the
government since we can't take them
violently out of the hands of the
government all we can do is by some Sly
roundabout way introduce something they
can't stop and quote when you think
about that is Bitcoin the only current
option we have to fulfill that kind of
promise or or at least you know Vision
that hyek had or are there other things
that uh you think could be maybe not
Bitcoin or blockchain related that could
potentially also so uh kind of get at
the same thing and and help to restore a
balance of power so there's nothing on
on my Horizon that really stands out
other than Bitcoin uh specifically you'd
have you know the blockchain combined
with having the most decentralized type
of it so small nodes proof of work uh
that seems to be the mo most robust uh
way to do it uh and then also you when
you have the network effects liquidity
uh your Network's now big enough to to
kind of stand up to pretty challenging
attacks anything that so far that kind
of uses other methods a central Hub and
that Central Hub is attackable um and so
some of the examples I use in the book
is like you know there is a firm that
like you know people could have like uh
accounts denominating gold ounces for
example or gold grams actually and you
could just easily trade them around and
you could do all this uh and then the
government just kind of shut them down
and of course we've had some emerge
since then um but really it's just it's
a chain of credit and so it's not it's
not fundamentally solving the problem I
think Bitcoin fundamentally solves the
problem because it creates a a whole new
Ledger uh that is actually at the root
about as decentralized as we can make it
there's still you know I there's like
supply chain uh concentrations to maybe
kind of try try to make a little bit
better there's a couple there's still a
handful of kind of um uh attack points
that are maybe not um you know 100%
decentralized but it's so far it's the
most decentralized thing I've seen uh
and I think that's the best shot we have
now in other countries I think stable
coins are serving a similar purpose
which is that uh you know if you're in
Argentina or basically if you're the
Argentinian government there's very
little you can do about stable coins
getting in and out of your country um
now the United States could go after
stable coins if for some reason they
decided they didn't like them anymore um
but Argentina can't or Nigeria can't and
so for people in those countries the
fact that there's a central Hub but that
Hub is outside of their jurisdiction and
it's able to kind of Pierce in there
peer-to-peer like that's that's the main
thing that these Technologies do is that
with all these little 160 different
currency bubbles really the only two
ways to bring money in or out are
physical ports of Entry which of course
are heavily surveilled and you can only
bring so much cash or gold through an
airport and the other one would be wire
transfers Bank basically various types
of Bank transfers or fintech overlays
which are still just essentially Bank
transfers and those those are also
heavily controlled by government
regulation uh whereas Bitcoin stable
coins similar types of assets you know
you can show a QR code on a video call
and send money you can send someone an
email with money you can dm with money
so as long as they're not like shut off
from the world like North Korea you can
send money in and out you can memorize
12 words and and just bring any any
amount of value density through an
airport um and so that that's just the
world that technology exists now and the
ones that have Central hubs can Pierce
into most countries and if you're going
to go after the biggest markets of all
um I think you have to be decentralized
at the root which is you know Bitcoin is
the closest thing we
have so I want to talk a little bit
about uh taking what you've called
broken money and highlight the critique
or U maybe the warning that is being
issued by people that the money could
become more broken and this gets into
the national debt this gets into what
appears to be a declining interest of us
treasuries so let's just start with the
debt itself we're now over $33.5
trillion uh in the United States we've
added over 500 600 billion in the last
month uh it seems like the problem is
getting worse and not actually uh um
providing any relief does the debt
matter and how do you evaluate this in
terms of uh the declining you know
strength of the US dollar or does it
actually not maybe come as correlated uh
as people would like it to be so I think
it does matter and people learned the
the wrong lesson about it about 30 years
ago and so for for people that kind of
track the kind of the nature of the
public debt back in the late 80s and
early 90s that's when concern about the
debt kind of reached a peak level uh
that was like the Zeitgeist of the time
so that the famous like Deb clock went
up in the late 80s uh Ross Pro ran the
most successful independent presidential
campaign in modern history running
mainly on the debt and deficit um and so
that was like an era and if you look at
the interest expense as percentage well
both in absolute terms and as expense as
a share of the economy that makes sense
because it was like soaring and so
people were like looking at this and
thinking this is literally it's going to
go like Yar this is this is completely
unsustainable um and but what a lot of
those people didn't expect is that we
would soon enter a 30-year period of
very strong disinflation um and so you
know China started to open up to the
world in the 80s and really kind of
accelerated that in the 90s and 2000s uh
Soviet Union fell and opened up
resources and labor the whole kind the
whole block opened up so basically we
took Western Capital combined it with
Eastern labor and resources and you just
had it on a pretty unprecedented period
of you know productivity growth
globalization uh and that was very
disinflationary and that allowed
industry rates to go down much lower
than anyone could have imagined uh in
that era and so even though we had
higher and higher debts and deficits the
whole time we also I was offset by ever
declining interest rates um but once we
hit zero and and kind of chop along for
a while and then uh bounce off zero
because there's more fiscal activity and
demographics are getting worse uh now we
we're kind of going back to that late
80s early 90s period where indust
expense is now rapidly accelerating and
even if you don't keep increasing
interest rates even if even if interest
rates now are just in a sideways pattern
between zero and 6% uh the fact that
we're still still adding more and more
debts and deficits uh with and it's
there's no longer an interest rate
offset let alone if you start to have
structurally higher interest rates um
but basically that is now rendering it
more acutely unsustainable uh and so we
have huge interest rate driven deficit
it and we have just no offset and it's
actually more of a US phenomenon than
the rest of the world uh Japan's in
situation us is in that situation
Europe's more mixed um but they also
have slower growth and so it's it's it's
really something that we're seeing a lot
in the developed world now and I think
people have spent the last 30 years
becoming too complacent around it um and
assuming that that kind of golden era of
peace and and exponential kind of um
productivity gains are going to last
even if the world doesn't get more
chaotic even if we avoid World War II
even if we don't you know decouple from
China if the mere fact that we don't
continue to accelerate in the way we
have if the status quo just starts to
kind of stagnate and we kind of you know
we already tapped into a lot of that
labor Arbitrage and that resource
Arbitrage and we just kind of hold it
steady that means we still have no
offset M mainly to what we what just
happen now there still are some like you
know Ai and other things like that can
still provide very strong
disinflationary impulse um but actually
goes back to the prior point of energy I
think ultimately energy is the big
constraint here uh in terms of the
ability to to run these big fiscal
deficits uh structurally without the
indust rate offset in a world where
energy is not getting remarkably
cheaper what becomes fascinating to me
is um Stanley drer Miller recently
critiqued Janet Yellen and uh treasur
secretary and said look why did we not
go ahead and refinance all of our debt
at these really low interest rates and
lock in long duration uh kind of debt I
think the counterargument would be that
maybe investors wouldn't have bought
long duration you know kind of low yield
debt how do you evaluate from a
country's perspective the citizens of
the country were out refinancing their
homes and kind of every single thing
that they possibly could when it just
trade stove does that the role of the
central bank or the treasury and and did
they make a mistake here or do you think
that actually uh maybe there was some
logic to what they were doing so I think
that um
while they could have around the margins
increased the average duration I mean
you know basically Austria launched a
100-year bond um so basically they they
made whoever bought that the bag holder
or whoever got caught with it when the
when the price actually started to go
down um the United States could have
done similar actions we could have had
50-year bonds 100y year bonds or just
issue more of the existing you know 10
20 30y year bonds the average duration
is something like six years on on us
treasuries um and a lot of it's
concentrated it's not like an a it's not
like an average thing it's more like a
lot of it's concentrated in the first
few years and then there's a long tail
that goes up to 30 years of of you know
just less of that I think your point is
correct and that that's what my
counterargument would be too is that had
they tried to like not just around the
margins but like meaningfully extend the
duration like if they made the average
duration 12 or 15 years for like the
whole the whole you know kind of debt
load um that would have prematurely
jacked race up and they probably would
have run into liquidity issues trying it
um I am kind of surprised they haven't
at least tried to do it more than they
could I think that's a valid criticism
why didn't why didn't you try to extend
uh average duration uh any more than you
did especially when there was such a
strong bid at the time for uh you know
those types of assets um but I think
that basically it was it was always
going to kind of end this way and
another thing is that if if if we
imagine a world where somehow they
managed to extend the debt a lot more
than they did maybe the average duration
15 years we would have had even worse
collateral issues in the banking system
uh among the public and so you probably
would have had other issues pop up that
would have ironically resulted in larger
deficits because us us um tax receipts
are so heavily tied to asset prices
going up and the economy doing well more
so than many other countries because
we're more financialized than them as
kind of the you know the global Reserve
currency issuer um and so it it's a lot
harder to say that that actually would
have really around the margins or at
least in a big way made a huge
difference now if we continue kind of
down this path of um you know a
valuating maybe your framework of why
the money's broken uh kind of what the
current financial situation is and where
we may be going I think there's a lot of
folks who are concerned in the uh about
the United States in the sense of we
have a national debt that's growing
quickly we have interest rate uh
payments that are growing quickly we now
have two essentially proxy wars both in
uh Ukraine and in Israel um and we feel
like uh there's a lot of money going out
and maybe not as much coming in as we
would like uh I believe the latest
number from the treasury is just going
to be about a $ 1.7 trillion deficit um
uh for the year and so it feels like all
of this is happening and interest rates
are already at you know five and a half
six percent and uh we haven't been
printing money and so if we continue
down this path we're going to have to
return to some sort of loose monetary
policy without even getting into a
recessionary period which also a whole
another group of people think that we're
headed towards and so is it something
where like we're in a bad spot and if we
are forced because of economic
conditions or because of geopolitical
decisions to go back to a loose monetary
policy prematurely that actually we can
go from a bad spot to an even worse spot
and the United States then kind of goes
closer and closer to you know quotequote
the edge or is that just you know
doomsayers on Twitter and elsewhere kind
of almost hoping for the implosion of
the United States and and maybe they
should be more careful about what they
wish for this episode is brought to you
by aradine there are a brand new startup
led by a number of Silicon Valley
Legends who just raised $81 million to
build the future of Internet
infrastructure you're wondering what
that means let me explain there are
numerous new disruptive technologies
that are being adopted simultaneously
from blockchain to artificial
intelligence to zero knowledge
Technologies in order to ensure that
these Technologies thrive in this new
world we need new infrastructure and
that is where arine comes in they just
launched their first product line called
Tera flux which is a Bitcoin miner
powered by the world's first 4 nanometer
silicon chip technology these air cooled
singlephase and dual phase emerging
cooling miners have unrivaled speed and
efficiency theyve Superior uptime and
they leverage a brand new innovation
called Energy tune that allows miners to
dynamically adjust the energy
consumption and Bitcoin hash rate based
on demand response needs of the
electrical grids aradine is an ambitious
company working on hard problems I'm
really impressed with them and if you
want to check out more you can go to
rodine.isfeld so I think the 2019 period
is destructive there when the when the
repo Market um blew up it's not
something that was like super popular
among people but anyone on macro would
be familiar with that event uh which is
basically just overnight the repo Market
that basically you know various
overnight lending just kind of blew up
uh and so the Federal Reserve had to hop
in and there were a number of us at the
time they were analyzing this and we're
like this is actually not a repo problem
it's actually just a t- bill over supply
problem uh basically liquidity kind of
hit its bedrock and repo just happened
to be used as the funding source for
treasuries uh by hedge funds and things
like that and so we were like that the
fed's going to have to you know stop QT
and buy t- bills here that's probably
what's going to happen and sure enough
uh you know a couple weeks later the Fed
was out there buying t- bills and then
trying to call it they was like this is
not QE we're just buying t- bills uh
which you know they people were joking
they started calling it not QE they were
like the fed's doing not QE um and you
know to to their point it wasn't exactly
QE because the purpose wasn't to
stimulate the economy the purpose they
weren't buying long duration they were
just basically fixing a plumbing issue
that was based on too much debt they
were they just had to kind of go back to
a degree of deficit monetization now of
course that wasn't a huge deal at the
time because we we weren't at above
average you know inflation levels at
least not by any meaningful degree so it
becomes a very different world If the
Fed eventually has a repeat of that
issue in a world where inflation's 3% 4%
5% or higher especially if there's Wars
happening things like that so I do think
that that's the eventual trajectory that
we're headed on is that there will be a
time where the Fed just has to go back
to balance sheet expansion kind of
regardless of what inflation's doing and
they're going to have a tough time kind
of communicating to the market why
they're doing that um and it could be
volatile as they try to push back
against doing that but basically if you
have something like the repo Market
break or the tradition Market go liquid
they're going to step in about as
quickly as we saw them step in the
banking crisis earlier this year I mean
they're trying to to cut down on
inflation you could have let um you know
some people lose unsecure deposits and
contract the money supply a little bit
they decided to go that route and I
think similarly if you have um you know
repo blowout treasury market blowout
something like that they're going to
just be that that's going to override
their other concerns now whether or not
that's a doom scenario I think that for
the first few years of that happening
that actually could feel like the next
bull market that could be this like
source of liquidity and it's like sure
inflation's above Target but things are
doing you know things are doing pretty
well and then ironically if you weaken
the dollar you could get like an
Emerging Market boom that's generally
how these go like a part of the reason
they did so well in the 2000s was
because we had a structurally weakening
dollar for several years and so the
brazils of the world uh the IND indias
of the world all these countries
basically had a boom because their their
debts were being kind of weakened uh
rather than hardened um and so that can
and that can of course feed back into
the United States where you know maybe
our econom is not outperforming everyone
else's but then we're actually getting
dragged along because ironically our
money problems are a a boon for them um
so I think especially in the early phase
it's not necessarily the the Doom that
people would would think it is right
away um but I think the the long-term
outcome is that we you know and this is
this is perhaps decades in the making is
that we do have a long-term monetary
change over um based you know from a
current system to whatever the next
system looks with some degree of
recapitalization uh it's like a you know
I don't like to use word reset because
everyone thinks everyone has they
picture of their head what reset means
basically recapitalization is like a
more specific thing which is basically
that these sovereign debt levels
basically get devalued in real terms in
one way or another um and they kind of
do the next system from there and so I
do think basically this is g to be an
issue it's going to be kind of a
fascinating and and for many people
hardship in in macro World winners and
losers and when people think about Doom
I mean I you know again you I I like to
refer to Egypt as an example I just I
spent the summer there and thir
inflation was 37% when I was there and
life went on people were driving people
were going to restaurants people were um
having fun and eating together and you
know it was obviously some people were
really struggling in that environment um
but it it's things that like our
threshold for Doom is like an average
Tuesday in many countries around the
world and so I do think we're going to
go through times in the years and
decades ahead that we've not really
experienced in the past 30 40 years that
other countries have and that we have in
the in the more distant past and that
that some people phrase that as Doom um
but it's it's both doom and it's it's
opportunity it's growth it's you know
challenging there I think the the only
way you get true Doom is to have
basically either Society breakdown true
energy shortages or major major war
those are the things that I would
consider outright Doom whereas monetary
changeovers are crisises but not
necessarily Doom is how I'd phrase it
last thing I want to talk about is um
there's a very interesting uh Trend that
seems to be occurring between bonds and
Bitcoin historically bonds have been
seen as a safe haven asset uh but since
there's been multiple geopolitical
conflicts we have seen bonds actually
trade down and so it seems like investor
interest uh is waning um to some degree
then when we look at Bitcoin Bitcoin is
up after those geopolitical events both
short-term and long-term um in some
cases like uh when we look all the way
back to Russia invasion of Ukraine
Bitcoin is up 50% since that moment now
it's a little hard to kind of understand
on the bond side hey how much of this is
just like the overall macro environment
and kind of Investments uh generally
pulling down but Bitcoin does seem to be
the outlier it does seem to be going up
when many other assets are are
correlating and going
down we then see Larry Fink Black Rock
CEO the largest money manager in the
world go on television and say hey
Bitcoin is a flight to Quality which I
think kind of surprise even people in
the Bitcoin Community saying wait that
guy is not supposed to be saying this
you know publicly on television is that
what's happening are like institutions
and these large money managers and kind
of people waking up to the fact that
Bitcoin is becoming the default Safe
Haven asset or are we maybe stretching
some of these data points and trying to
tell a story that really isn't there yet
I think both are true and the way I
would describe it first is that so the
closest correlate I have found to
bitcoin price action is global liquidity
uh and so for example if I take Global
broad money supply denominated in
dollars which means there's two big
components of it one is how fast or
money supplies expansion especially the
you know the top 10 monies and then two
how strong is the dollar relative to
them which is really important because
that's what a lot of global debt is
denominated in that's that's like the
your your liability unit of account um
when the dollar is weakening or when
money the money printers are on uh
Global liquidity that that Global
liquidity metric goes up quite a bit and
Bitcoin tends to be very correlated with
that to the upside the down side if you
look at in absolute terms or rate of
change terms you'll see it it's arguably
more correlated than the is although the
having helps too I think but basically
it's it's one of those highly correlated
things and most risk Assets in general
like and our Define risk asset is
volatile asset that's how that's how
most um Capital kind of allocators would
treat it um most of those are correlated
with liquidity uh but so far Bitcoin
seems to be more correlated with
liquidity which I think makes sense
because it it it's stripped away from
other factors like uh earnings and
things like that it's basically when
you're deciding whether or not you want
to own this scarce emerging money um um
expansion of the broad money supply Glo
globally tends to be fuel for that and
if you have contractions or stagnations
in that um usually people are are not
pouring into Bitcoin and they're they're
more defensive elsewhere so I think some
of it is like literally just that um you
know Bitcoin kind of bottomed when
liquidity bottomed and has been rising
with kind of like we're not really in a
booming liquidity environment right now
but we're not as bad as it was and say
late
2022 um but the other factor is like I I
talked to some Bank board of directors
or institutional allocators and there is
a changing of the view like um when I
talk about things like fiscal dominance
or uh the risk of a fiscal spiral or you
know things like that or talking about
structurally higher inflation for a
period of time things that might have
gotten you called a cook you know four
years ago uh instead of like you know
the the board of directors like scoffing
when you're saying this they're all kind
of nodding along like yeah that makes
sense uh basically it's it it's slowly
becoming kind of more aware that we are
in kind of unusual times and and so I I
think that basically people are taking
things like Bitcoin gold uh hard Assets
in general more seriously than they
would have a few years ago um and you
know every time kind of the way that
I've described it before is that people
in the Bitcoin space they most people
have seen like the log price chart of
Bitcoin at this point and they see it
you know it's got like you know four
Cycles to it most people have actually
not seen that chart um and if they've
seen the chart they kind of dismiss it
um what I think m for people is not how
many how many times bitcoin's risen From
the Ashes it's how many times they've
seen it Rise From the ases Ashes because
if they see a Bitcoin boom and they it
captures their attention for the first
time and then they see it crash their
view was okay this is exciting oh it's
dead if they see it come back a second
time you know that's when a lot of
people have that like wake up moment
they're like wait a second that's
actually a thing um and for some people
maybe takes a third time uh not not of
Bitcoin having that cycle but them
literally seeing that cycle
and I think that it's kind of getting to
the point where especially after the um
2017 bull market that that was big
enough that it got on a lot of people's
Radars obviously the the 2021 one uh got
even on more people's Radars um and if
they started to see a sign that it's it
might have another one that maybe this
thing isn't dead after all like they
might have written it off as people
start to actually take it more seriously
and I I think that's that's around at
least around the margins I think that's
what we're
seeing ly broken why our financial
system is failing Us and how we can make
it better it's available on Amazon and
everywhere else uh it is I think as I
told you before uh the perfect mix
between uh academic rigor and uh an
entertaining read that kind of makes you
continue to Contin uh to kind of go
through Page by Page um what was the one
most surprising part of the whole
process is there one thing that kind of
sticks out to you that you're like yeah
I didn't expect that but it was kind of
a pleasant uh surprise as you
experienced it I think how much I learn
while writing a book even though most of
the book was already like when I started
writing the book The reason it came out
quickly is because I already had like
the outline pretty much there uh a lot
of it was just going to draw from my
existing research with a couple new
ideas I wanted to really kind of
emphasize um but going into the nooks
and crannies of like each chapter I
would find like new things that I I
didn't know like when I was digging into
kind of banking system of the
Renaissance Era or digging into the
nuances of the brenon wood system uh
things like that there's these a lot of
times when you go to teach something you
know you you end up learning it even
more because when you're teaching
something you want to be sure of what
you're trying to teach and so you end up
kind of you know crossing your tees and
dotting your eyes in a way that you
might not do if you were just learning
something you can if you're learning
something you can be like you can get 80
or 90% of it like yeah I get most of it
whereas if you're teaching it you go
back to other like 10 20% and really
make sure that there's nothing kind of
hidden there or nothing that's going to
throw off your your view or things that
could be very surprising and so digging
into some of those um resources uh I was
you know kind of just um like super just
kind of excited to see how much I
learned even just as an attempt to
educate along the way I think people
know at this point uh I read quite a bit
um this is one of my favorite books of
the last year so thank you so much for
taking the time to write it I know it
wasn't easy although uh you will humbly
say that you already had most of the
outline you still had to sit down and
write 500 pages or so um and obviously I
think people are going to learn a lot
from it so thank you so much and we'll
definitely do this again in future I
appreciate that thank you